is the SAT racist everyone seems to
think it is including colleges they're
dropping the SAT because they say it's
biased against minorities but don't
believe them in fact standardized tests
like the SAT actually help disadvantaged
students prove their smarts new data
shows SAT scores predict student
achievement better than high school GPA
rich kids have a big advantage on other
things schools use to evaluate students
like essays and grades why as it turns
out grade inflation is highest at
private schools which means rich kids
can get better grades even without
earning them an essay quality is more
closely related to family income than
SAT scores without standardized tests
colleges will judge applicants based
only on the things Rich families can buy
if you don't believe me ask MIT when MIT
brought back the test requirement in
2022 they ended up admitting their most
diverse class on record so if you want
to help disadvantaged students you
should love standardized tests